die mit der infizierten wunden die
vorsorge heute noch genauso wichtig ist
dass kleins zwischendurch immer hoch zu
legen gerade wenn sie ruhig haben sich
gucken oder so oder mal mitmachen
genau damit die lymphflüssigkeit einfach
ein bisschen abfließen kann sollte auch
immer die wundheilung damit die
wundervollen getroffen haben vor haben
wir das schönes infizieren damit wie die
bakterien keime einmal reduzieren oder
abtöten können die wurde sieht ja
insgesamt deutlich besser ausland also
genau die infektion das loch sichtbar
dies ist der mit den schmerzen aktuell
könnte ok ich denke immer dass man das
runde extra dort aufnehmen kann
das ist einfach nicht durch dezimiert
das ist immer wichtig das war musste und
auch ruhig dann auch die patienten
fragen ob das zu fest ist oder nicht
mehr weil jetzt haben wir die
möglichkeit dann auch noch was zu tun
geht es so wunderbar deshalb das waren
wieder ablegen
genau und einmal gut festhalten wichtig
ist dann auch wirklich die mullbinde
nochmal zu fixieren damit dass weg
sowohl für das rätselhafte doch ganz gut
gemacht weil gerade am unterschenkel der
patientin sich aber noch viel bewegen
möchte oder sind das nicht runter
rutscht und da kannst du hier noch mal
kontrollieren wenn er so ein verein
passt dass es auch nicht zu eng ist ja
doch ganz ruhig mal probieren ja genau
ansonsten verband darauf lassen nicht
rangehen und auch nicht nass machen
prima ist klar
[Musik]